Clapperton chuck in that some of Ungers
professional interests lie in the
history theory and practice of science,
technology,
innovation and entrepreneurship in the
international context with a focus on
Africa.
He joined MIT as an assistant professor
in 2008 after completing his phd at the
University of Michigan.
He is the author of transient workspaces
technologies of everyday innovation in
Zimbabwe. And his second book is an edited
volume which we'll hear about today.
Entitled what do science, Technology
and innovation mean from Africa.
Please join me in welcoming
professor [inaudible].
Thank you.
Uh,
thank you all for coming.
I would like to,
mmm,
start off by giving just a brief
background to how this project came about.
MMM.
It's a progression from my first
book, uh, transit work spaces.
And what I was trying to do in that
book was to ask this fairy important
question.
Why is it easy that in the history of
technology science into innovation,
Africa does not seem to be on the map,
is a question that he does not have any
technology or simply that it has been
ignored.
So as you know,
Africa is a very big continent.
54 countries,
uh,
probably plus if you include the islands.
And this is not something that you
can just, you know, cover inside,
uh, one book on your own
in a short period of time.
So I wanted to ask this question
on a larger scale in these,
was the birth of this book,
take a closer look at the title,
the major Eh,
where there is from.
The idea was to take
seriously African voices,
not just his empirical evidence
or cannon fodder for theory,
but is,
um,
intellectual agents in their own right.
What if we took what they
know seriously enough
to do that I organized
in number of scholars,
some of them mentors to me, others, uh,
colleagues at the same level.
Da, my Solo at Louisville,
a shattering cheery Korea
at University of Cape Town,
Sheree or Gusto at Brown Katrine
[inaudible] you live in runny egg lash,
who some of you may know it. Rpi, uh,
and then Foresta he's
student, um, totally.
Or do Masu and got it.
Louis,
both of them at University of Virginia,
both engineers and they are colleagues.
Nasima.
So the idea was could we have a
conversation across disciplines?
Eh,
I didn't want this idea of us just
the science and technology studies,
people speaking to ourselves.
I wanted to open up this
conversation to multiple disciplines.
The bench sciences, engineering
disciplines, lawyers.
The conference that I
organized in November 19th,
2014 was
actually very eclectic is,
and actually it,
this became the actual
title of the book. Uh, uh,
we haggled over this. Some of you may
know from publishing that publishers,
one is set in type of title
for marketing reasons.
I said, no, this is the title.
Like I said, there's this
persistent negative image of Africa,
but there is also the agency of some
of us working on Africa to escape it.
Other stifling, uh, Western, uh,
dependence on theory.
Could we imagine science,
technology and innovation from say,
our own languages.
Okay.
I look at definitions of science,
technology and innovation today and I'm
sure you would agree that they are very
reductionist science comes to be,
eh,
removed from a all kinds
of social dimensions.
But as we know,
science itself is a social activity.
The idea was to restore that and see
where we would get in Africa for example,
it's impossible to reckon with any major
innovation without ticking seriously
religious aspects that under good
the ritual of knowledge production.
The same for technology.
If you look at technology today,
it's as if it's just a technical gadgets.
Um,
and I'm seeing they said Google,
um,
but it's a whole complex systems,
social,
technical, cultural, etc. Etc.
My interest was to restore that,
but all sorts of disturb
the meaning of technology.
Is it that obvious or
could it be something more?
Could it be that we are
in being in reducing it to
gadgets we are missing out on
something else?
What could that something
else be the same with,
um,
if you look at innovation,
innovation has been reduced to
this very commercialized tech,
techno centric, uh, rearm. So what are we,
what are we to do with those activities
that people engage with that fall
outside that
now,
why did these conversations
or care when they did,
this was just a year before I got
tenure at 2015 and I was beginning to be
frustrated by the insula way in which
academia engages with questions of the
world.
Um,
and so I began to engage policy makers.
For example,
could I see myself playing a role
making interventions in policy?
Okay.
I had been conducting research since
2008 on what I call everyday knowledge.
That knowledge that sustains
people when, uh, the,
our Nice Gary as a here,
Eh,
when people don't have those careers,
they never went to school or
if they were fired from work.
Many of these people in Africa,
going back to what is now called
informal sector or the informal economy,
what under girds the informal activity,
uh,
these skills that you
need to go by every day.
Most of them are not in the curriculum.
In the school curriculum.
A good number of them actually dismissed,
uh,
traditionally is primitive
or simply and knowledgeable.
So I see they started this 2000 and
this project 2008 by then I had already
began to hear this talk.
Africa is rising, Eh,
you seeing a new young African who
is quite driven to make a difference.
The,
there is one generation that still says
colonialism is to blame for all our eels
theater now that says no, no, no. We
have been independent for a while.
Could this nonsense,
this generation that I am talking about,
the younger generation,
I felt they needed a different kind of
narrative about African deeply rooted in
history but also tackling the key,
uh, keywords in their own time. Like tech,
like science, like innovation,
like entrepreneurship.
Okay.
And yet when you look at Africa's history
is a blank slate. Historians have you,
not that anthropologists,
yeah,
they are beginning to come round to it
is for engineering, science and tech.
They don't deal with that stuff.
Okay.
So each nation subsists on
its own meats and to heroes.
What kind of euros with
this generation subsystem.
Okay.
That's the busiest for,
I'm writing this book.
It was intended for what?
Since the book was published.
He has now, uh, image,
the clearly in my mind is a project
of training critical thinkers.
Doers.
Okay.
In other words is to see that Africa
is a load of critical thinkers,
but most of them are not.
Do us and those that actually do
things are not critical thinkers.
So how do you bring these
two and square the circle.
Okay.
The research that I had done
since both during and since Phd,
he had taught me that the best way to be
effective in the world is to be humble
before knowledge to not appear like you
monopolize the space of common sense and
reason.
Yeah.
And that was coming from
being at MIT is in academic.
And what I learnt in my fieldwork and
through growing up was a lot of knowledge
that is handed down from generation
to generation through practice.
Okay.
And part of this required me to have
to really look at Africa in a different
light is somebody was coming
back from years in the diaspora.
Okay.
I found that one of the most
underestimated strengths,
the most underrated,
eh,
acids of Africa is what one
would call creative resilience.
Where even when people's
backs are against the wall,
they don't just die, roll over
and die. They die fighting.
And so that creative spirits
is often take ignored.
People just talk about,
oh Africa's people are very resilient.
Look at what is thrown at them.
Okay.
No, it's not just the
resilience, it's also creativity.
You can be resilient or all you want,
but if you are faced with hunger in death,
you have to innovate.
Okay.
The concern for me was that a lot
of what is what we are seeing now,
uh,
in the context in terms of innovation
arises out of trying to make due to deal
with a very tough situation.
So let me take you through the individual
chapters in the process of answering
this question. What do science, technology
and innovation mean from Africa?
I have seen that I held him,
Eh,
W I convened a meeting at Mit in 2014 I
had also organized the previous one in
South Africa to recast
the idea of laboratory.
Okay.
Why recast it?
Because I don't believe that the built
laboratory is the only laboratory that
exists.
If we limited to that,
we are shutting out the
door a lot of possibilities.
Okay.
Now where would you start with this?
The first port of call for me
was could we engage philosophers?
We have been dealing with a lot of these
questions about African knowledge and
so in the chapter that
Di da Macello rights,
it's a very interesting
example from Egypt.
The concern for the afterlife in
how it give rise to the science of
magnification.
Okay.
And this discovery of [inaudible],
which was used to preserve the body.
And one of the theories,
the advances is that this was the
rationale for turning to not Ron in
mummifying,
a body or a preserving it in a fridge
state was saw that it could travel the
journey to the afterlife in a fresh
state in instead of arriving the in a de
composting.
Okay.
Now,
however we may think about the belief
systems of the ancient Egyptians is not
the question here.
Okay.
Usually in the past, African knowledge
has been dismissed. Oh, this is cuckoo.
That can't happen.
Okay.
And yet when you look at
the science that follows,
we surely that's what we just take and
say, okay, this is what we hold on to.
The rest is rubbish.
Muscle also touches on what is often
conceived of as a primitive society in
trying to find technology
and innovation in that space.
The Messiah of Kenya and buy other parts
of East Africa and how they have been
to both maintain salient aspects
of designing spears is will is
adopting and adapting some
elements that are coming in.
In my own chapter I focused on
something different.
I wanted to see if we can really think
about science from a truly indigenous
language
and if we did that,
what kind of keywords
might we come up with
and what I found was quite interesting
in
several parts of the of the chapter,
I give the example of the way in which
observations of animals and animal
science
give rise to a whole way
of defending agonist,
enemy attack in constructing
defense systems.
My best is mice is a rule.
Mice always have a plan B.
When they dig they have two exits.
One is the obvious one.
The other is the other you don't see,
so they enter this way.
If you wait here and think that the
mouse is going to come back this way
and
you are already poised to hit it,
oops,
it has already bolted the other
way it's gone. When he digs,
there are all these
various covens that it,
it it highs in,
so you may be digging this way and it
takes a detour and just highs there.
Okay.
Mice are also known to be very good
at defending against siege warfare.
One example,
I give the these,
these tick and squirrels do this as well,
but in this case it was mice.
Okay.
And this had very substantial
consequences to the concept of Chimeranga.
The idea that women would be stalking
food in the caves while all the men who
would be busy mounting the defenses.
It was a communal effort.
Yeah.
What I'm interested is not so much the
the war I tend to be until I am much more
interested in the idea that you could
learn a lot of things from other animals
and I'm sure if you look at some of
the science that that's coming out,
like get skin for example.
It's coming out of this idea to learn the
animal world in order for you to apply
to other papers is full
shattered to query.
The interesting thing was to think about
the laboratory is a site which is not
fixed or ticket to space.
It's something that is moving.
You can lift it and press it way.
What remains constant is the practice.
And for these example this,
this is a stunning example of how
you could actually build furnaces,
blast furnaces in clay
in order to smelt iron.
Okay.
And do so in a way that is capable
of being shifted elsewhere.
Okay.
And I'm calling this science because how
else do you explain the fact that these
ironsmiths on the Zimbabwean plateau in
Congo in the 16th to 18th centuries they
out competed the Portuguese,
we had come with their engineers
from Europe to construct foundries.
Okay.
And the Portuguese, Lo and behold they
couldn't Benatar. They'll hold the lock.
Our market, in fact they did not
even have confidence in their own.
Yeah.
Iron and then they deferred to this
locums in order to continue to be viable.
Okay.
Part of what I find interesting is the
way in which these ironsmiths we're able
to manipulate air supply.
Okay.
To initiate combustion and control it
to know what kind of trees were required
to provide wooed with goods,
charcoal and to be able to do so in such
a way that they prepare the charcoal
under specific conditions.
Okay.
That's science.
There is no way we can go around it.
So I am working as one of the
two activities that she recorded.
It looks at the other one is Porterie.
Porter is interesting because
it's practiced by women,
mostly women in Africa. I've not heard
of societies where men are to be found,
you know, making pots. No.
If I had of until perhaps the,
the recent times of any
women smelting iron,
both we're governed by taboos.
If a woman comes near
anywhere near the finish,
the,
I don't know,
not come out nicely and the same time
if a men came anywhere near where women
were making pots,
they would crack.
That was the taboo.
Production could only take place
under these specific conditions.
Nothing else.
And before anything was done,
these folks had to go before
their ancestors and the gurus of,
of, of technology. If you want to
see this is what we are going to do.
Okay.
If anything failed they would
blame the failure to observe taboo.
Taboo may sound strange,
doesn't it?
It's nothing more than the kinds
of things that you do in science.
Science is its own taboos here the do's
and don'ts under which an experiment is
carried out.
Okay.
We often think of innovation is something
that we all are free to and if you
look at the narrative of innovation,
it is usually this independent
spirit of creativity and risk taking,
particularly by the o think slavery.
How do you innovate Eh,
freedom or how do you innovate survivor
or alive under bondage when your life
has been reduced to nothing more than
a machine of mass production on the
plantation. That's the focus
of of urea or gastro stopped.
She is trying to reposition the Trans
Atlantic trade in Africans is leaves,
I don't call it slave trick.
Okay.
Is it technology transfer
and innovation process?
The argument she's making through seeds
and medicines is an interesting one that
it's easy to say they were
carriers of ready made
products from Africa or knowledge
in their heads from Africa.
That's easy to say,
eh?
Some scholars have said that
for ice, others, for Mass Henri,
others for mentors,
the work of kindness,
Gaucho for example,
but what she's saying is that in that
space between departure and arrival,
enslaved Africans hit to survive.
The only way you survive was to
keep yourself with high morale.
Of course there was also the possibility
that you could recruit yourself from
the space of being molested by your
character and just jump over Borden ended
and denied them profit.
Yeah.
That way still very creative
and a difficulty comes in
system or you could take
only those,
those resources that you had,
there was nothing else to
work with and shift them,
inform,
transform them in order
to create something that
would enable you to survive.
So the space between
departure and arrival
was not a dead space.
It was a creative space,
what she calls the Inter Trans,
the in between at the same
time when they arrived.
Picture yourself arriving in a foreign
environment where you have to eek out a
living even as you are enslaved.
Okay.
What she is calling attention to is
to look at the slave quarters is an
innovation space.
Okay.
I liked this picture because partly
tills biography of me growing up
where a lot of things were not,
did not have space locally we,
it was during sanctions and I saw the
Rhodesian community innovating in very
interesting ways,
replacing imported parts with local ones
that they could easily manufacture and
when they ran their life they actually
began to manufacture them locally.
Examples include a lot of the Humvees
that you see in the battlefields in the
Middle East that are
coming from Australia.
Much of that r and d was Rhodesian met
these auditions then migrated after
independence. They did not want to have
to be ruled by a blood governments.
They migrated.
That's one narrative.
The other narrative
that's interesting is that
okay,
if you wanted your mom
to cook food for you,
you had to make the utensils
and it started to process it.
Okay.
In precolonial Africa for example,
they will know hammer mills,
they will know steam machines.
The only way you could bow,
you could grind grain and produce
meal was to produce mortar and pestle.
And what you see in this picture is a
process it dad taking his son through the
process of how you make one
and to the point until you,
your mother actually pounds
a grain to make food for you.
At Mit we talk of mind in hint,
this is his mind and hinders.
You can get the subject of
total or the Moses chapter
is an interesting one
because you are hearing more
and more. Now Africa being
referred to is leap frogging.
For most of Africa there
was no land fixed land line
then comes cyber,
which by the way did not come.
Cell phones did. They did not
come just by the grace of God.
Norway, they brought by
foreigners. The first,
the pioneers of cell phones in Africa,
so phone or broads
cylinder foreign to Africa.
Okay
included people like me,
worldwide tare,
Eh ou founded at telesales
for us to have
undersea cables.
That Sitcom navigated the Cape.
That idea was pushed very vociferously
by former South African prison.
Didn't tableau ambig
his argument was simple.
There was one slot reserved for hosting
the World Cup for 2010 and it would go
to an African country. No.
Which guns would it be?
Would it be Egypt,
Egypt, last two funnels.
In any case it was almost right on the
path of the undersea cables going to
India.
The argument doesn't make,
he was making was interesting.
If Egypt gets the World Cup,
I forgot it's lost its
chance to have is a,
you know
Internet each way.
It is lost as jazz so the only way it's
getting heavy it is if the cop came to
South Africa, we now know that if you look
at the map, the site by map of Africa,
that is come to be,
it come to pass.
Since then we have seen
interesting developments.
We have seen innovations in mobile money
with empaysah which is revolutionizing
not just African, Eh, Eh,
how African's movement.
It's the revolutionizing the way the
whole world does mobile banking and so
forth.
The latest innovation is by
ziplining international in Rwanda.
A partnership that is resulted in the
supply of blood to difficult to reach
countries using drones and by uh,
and,
and these is now expanding into Tanzania.
These things have policy implications.
For example,
how can his sensibility of Africa is
the center of technology sheep policy.
Yeah.
And part of the reason
why we produced this
volume when we did is because we were
concerned that the strategic plan for
Africa,
the science,
technology and innovation strategy
for Africa focus is on big science and
national systems of innovation derived
from mostly European countries.
Wu's uh, economies, um,
science intensive. They are
research intensive. By contrast,
70% of Africa's economy is generated,
you know,
the informal sector produced by that
everyday knowledge that I highlighted
earlier.
One.
So part of what Chuck's done it was does,
is to try and retain us to it.
That kind of conversation.
Can we have something more sophisticated
than just cutting and pasting in
closing, I've talked so
far about a, what we did,
this is what has happened since
the impeditive now is to transform
some of these findings into actual
curriculum.
So we have been turning
the networks that we,
we built through this process into
silver by like this for example,
how about we take students
to these sites like this uh,
forge here and taking seriously
the science involved in
this and combine it with
engineering.
What might we get?
How about we take knowledge of
grain storage under which um,
Africans Dogg underground or constructed
structures made of clay and he did them
and after heating and it's cool they,
they,
they put grain insight and then seal
it thereby ensuring that no weevils
getting,
what are we need to make up of that
is opposed to using all these
toxic pesticides to preserve gray.
Okay.
Finally I will say that
one of the things that I've
been trying to do is to demystify
the purpose of education.
And this is an admitted
that is dear to my heart.
When we are educated,
we leave the villages with
the communities and go abroad.
We never come back and many of
these insights as good as they were,
they were produced by
academics and these academics.
What do we do?
Does it just end in talk?
I said earlier that Africa
is a huge deficits of doers,
a lot of critical thinkers.
We're not do us a lot of doers.
We're not critical thinkers.
The challenge personally was what have
I ever done because I want to change the
whole of Africa.
I want to change the world.
What if I ever really done
for my own little village?
And so I wanted to challenge fill
academics who come from Africa to say,
can't we be catalysts and builders?
So I returned to home,
remodeled my own homestead into a kind
of laboratory where I could try out if I
had ideas that I thought worked,
why not try the about face to see if
they work before I can propose them to
governments.
I can just talk from,
that's empty rhetoric.
Okay.
And as you spend substantial
presence in the village,
you realize that actually people
where they work every day,
these are their own laboratories.
Like this young man here who told me
that if you want to see if one fertilizer
works amount three of them
just to plant three crops,
right? Three plants,
right? One, two, three.
And then put the same amount
of fertilizer on each.
Okay,
three different.
The one that grows more
is justified itself is the better option
so you could come to that
space is a learner and not
just somebody who's telling
people what to do.
Finally,
there is a concept that I talk about in
the introduction coach an under which
this society came together
to do communal work,
the whole village
to do community work for women who are
widowed for orphans or those that were
too old to do work or simply for those
that had excelled and go to overwhelmed
by their own crop production.
It's called Nimby.
It's an ethos of collective work.
The idea that I was bringing back was,
can't we do this again but this time
focusing on self development in the
village, the picture, you'll
see what's ticking this morning.
Ets,
it peaked ya off.
US electrifying our own
village using that concept.
It's not easy.
There will be people who are still very
individualistic but you just didn't out.
Once you cut off the rough edges,
it has turned out to be a very,
very successful model.
Thank you very much for listening.
Okay.
You reminded me of an,
excuse me,
an experience I had recently
with the community garden. Um,
it is, uh, near here.
It is not individual plots
where people in the community,
it has done communally as a group and
many of the people in that maybe be most
in that group are engineers and
a lot of the engineers from MIT.
And uh,
I learned from there that farmers in the
u s at least in the western world don't
innovate.
Hmm.
The industry of selling them
products does the development,
the innovation and sells them
answers to their questions basically.
Um, so they don't ask
questions at all of themselves,
but clearly in a village you get this
sense of being not just empowered but,
but required to ask an answer your own
questions or they will never be known.
Um,
it seems a natural thing for
a village environment or a,
um,
a group large enough to be able to
differentiate who is doing what work,
but small enough that everyone is an
individual and everyone can hear what one
person has to say to, to do
that kind of innovation, um,
to learn perhaps that one other kinds
of one kind of tree blocks the wind a
better when the wind is
making it difficult for
young, young plants. Yeah. Um,
so thank you for bringing that to light,
but very much clicked with me
based on my personal experience.
Thank you so much.
I'm curious if,
if you see one particular nation in
Africa or a particular city or region,
um,
as the most likely to sort of export
the next world changing technology or,
or if that doesn't really
matter so much and if,
if you're more focused on some of the
work you've shared today that really has
low direct local impact in communities,
Rwanda,
Rwanda.
Because if you look at what a
President Paul, I mean, is doing,
he's willing to take risks.
I was very impressed by the story that,
Eh, the, Eh,
killer Rinaldo from Ziploc and told me
he was saying that everybody else, yes.
Laughter. Boff basic
garden even, you know,
the big pharmaceutical companies,
uh,
the big foundations in the United
States, uh, let alone government,
they just said, yeah, crazy
little boy get out of here.
But [inaudible] was prepared to take
the risk and they buy loaded that the
first,
it's a world's first actually.
So that'll needs on what's happening is
very interesting where you already have
done better.
So that to see nothing awful shade.
Now one could say,
oh,
but these people are coming from outside
or the big corporations in the kids
that are doing this.
But why is it that it's possible in Africa
and what kind of infrastructures are
they creating?
Zip Line is very interesting.
Where it goes next will be critical.
So I would say Wanda,
without any doubt. Second do,
which would be malicious.
Uh,
I think the big innovation will
be in problem solving. Education.
Uh,
you have two institutions.
One in Maritia scald
African leadership academy.
They now university. Um, and they uh,
modeling their education
system is declaring you
declare a student declares not
a major but emission
and one of their missions is
to solve global challenges.
I she had seen in Ghana is doing the
same thing I think differently though,
but I would watch the one in Mauritius.
I work on education initiatives at Google.
I was wondering if you could provide
a little bit more specific information
about those examples that
you just mentioned where
there are these educational
models around mission,
right.
Rather than knowledge for
the sake of knowledge.
Where can I go and learn
more information about that?
Um, they, so the thing with with,
with upper leadership university is
that there is a big vision and they have
started that journey to get there and
they are on a big recruitment drive.
That's how I go to know that in
the interest of full disclosure,
what interests me about them is
that they are willing to gamble,
take big risks and start
entirely something new.
They are not interested in settled
waters because you know when the water is
crystal create,
you will see where the crocodile is.
They are prepared to plunge in and gamble
that the crocodiles will see that they
are too brave. They must be
banking on something and back off.
So their website is a good start,
but they are very approachable.
In terms of Fred, you got this founder
himself is very, very approachable.
They are mixing this corporate
style of doing things with,
I can't say traditional way
of delivering education,
but that's that corporate style is
interesting because when he has a vision,
he can push it forward.
Please join me again and thank you,
professor Malanga.
Thank you so much.